how i know for a fact there's no aliens
there's no ufos because when you become
president united states they tell you
all the secrets yeah
give it up and you know if they told
trump there's some aliens that mother
sucker is telling people
oh i know there's alien he can't keep a
secret first of all so i really believe
that
yes do you no no no no i really believe
that he's gonna just
no run his mouth you know what the other
day i had uh i had a
uh i had a mike baker on okay mike baker
is a former ci agent this interview is
going to go live here soon
we had a good conversation together you
know what i asked him i said how long is
a cia agent cia agent so
it depends 24 years 40 years sure how
long is the president or president
four years maybe eight years if you're
fdr maybe you know
16 years 13 years right not anymore but
yeah anymore but you know what i'm
saying is
four to eight years but a ci agent 20 30
years i said do you think
when the president becomes a president
they tell him everything
do you think the person that knows
everything about everything that's ever
happened in the history of america
that's kept secret say
you know area 515 area 51 you think
they will tell the president everything
i don't believe that
i don't believe you're a person sitting
here
you've been doing it for 32 years you
know stuff that
99.999 percent of the world doesn't know
and you get a new guy
who was an entrepreneur a one-term
senator
a guy that likes to rub people's back
okay
who becomes a president a guy that is a
smooth talker from arkansas a guy that's
you know very what's wrong with arkansas
yeah what's
saying that they don't tell the
president you think they're going to
tell the president
i suppose that there's close to it let
me ask you a question what is the track
record of any president that's been able
to keep
every secret to themselves what's the
track record of a president who's
extremely ambitious
who's extremely competitive to reveal an
information to him that's he's going to
be able to keep it to himself
you don't think a president is going to
sit there and say let me tell you what i
just found out today
let me tell you something i was just in
area 51. dude i saw
three headed ufos
i took a picture they check this out i
told the guy take a picture i'll take a
picture with you so he took a picture
with you
you're taking selfies with aliens i
don't think i don't think
presidents know everything i'm telling
you i don't think presidents know
everything i don't know who the person i
asked the guy said
who is the person that knows everything
he says i don't know there's got to be i
would say that's pretty true because i
couldn't even keep
everything from hillary someone was
always telling her stuff that's right
i was in hot water all the time clinton
ago i thought i was actually pretty good
my guy i'm a clinton guy that's right so
sorry i don't i don't know
i don't know i don't know if they told
trump everything you think they told
trump everything else you imagine well
if they did that secret would be in the
game no way
in the world they say everything okay
there is
no way in the world you think trump
would have used the information he knew
to threaten them
let's uh hey look you know there's this
has been going back
since kennedy and you know we'll stay
away from conspiracies and stuff
but jfk said that he was very concerned
about the clandestine side of the cia
because it was this inherently super
secret part of the us government
that was set aside from congress and it
was set aside from the president
it was set aside from senate senate
declares war congress makes budget
president leads a nation with vision and
you know certain legislative agendas
with it and so he was pointing out here
we are this is the
checks and balances the bicameral system
of government
and we have a supreme court to help keep
us all honest when the big arguments
break out
meanwhile over here in the other side of
the defense department you've got the
clandestine
c.i.a and it was jfk that said this is
bad
and so i i'm with pat not only do they
not tell the president
they don't tell them anything they don't
tell themselves i don't think it's a
good strategy to tell the president
i don't think so either i don't think
it's to me you you know no
i'm backing you up and you're saying jfk
when i talk to jonah this
he thought it was dangerous by the way
somebody said trump started starford's
let me give credit to the person that's
facebook facebook i'd love to get our
audience no this guy wrote star force he
said
didn't trump create star force he's
raised forces yeah but but
okay go ahead sorry yeah if you're if
you're listening i'm actually curious go
ahead adam i'm curious i want to see
what our audience has to say do they
believe in aliens or
or or not yeah if you believe aliens
exist
press thumbs up if you think they don't
exist press thumbs down like let's just
say if you're part of the megalodon
community
put thumbs down if you're part of the
ufo community put thumbs up but here's a
question i'm talking to chief disguise
officer
jonah mendez okay and what jonah mendes
did is she
would make a mask looking like you
and walking and sitting right next to
president bush and president bush would
think adam is in and it looks
identical to you and there's even a
picture of her doing a mask of who
a mask of anybody's face prosthetics
she did she was a chief disguise officer
of the cia that was her job what a job
to have exactly wow
28 years her and her husband by the way
okay
the role play they had going on who i
said i said do you guys even trust each
other if you're married to each other
he's 32 years you're 28 years old
exactly that's what it would be that uh
paulina porter closer i heard anything
tonight can you believe that so i asked
the question i asked the question i said
so here's a question for you says what's
that
what what's the qual what's the what are
the great qualities of a ci agent the
greatest cigan ever
what are great qualities of a cia agent
he said she said it's very simple
very charming great salespeople wow
incredible with people they know how to
get you to like them
you'll love them they're extremely
ambitious but there's one thing they
have
that the rest of the world doesn't have
i said what's that
when they discover what osama bin laden
did and they saved the world
when they go get intel from russia or
china
and it was because of them that they
saved the world they don't need any
recognition they're not looking for
glory
they don't need any right yeah that's
what
made a great ci agent because they don't
go and say hey baby you won't even
believe what i did tonight so you know
the scanning osama let me
we met an osama the other day two nights
ago three nights ago if you remember
that right
so yeah yeah you know you know the
scandal some of you so i kind of stopped
the whole thing tonight no you didn't
like imagine you made a girl at the bar
so what do you do for a living i work at
uh this accounting firm i'm one of the
accountants there how about yourself
what do you do
i kind of took out this kind of osama
that's right land a helicopter in his
backyard walk upstairs aired him out
what do you do you need to be here a
charismatic
a people person but you're not looking
for the attention you
minus recognition okay yeah that's a
problem for you yeah i mean
just tag me in a photo i don't care what
you say i got it
that's all i need tag me in the photo so
but that's very interesting yeah so the
point i'm trying to make to you is
what is a president's dna a president
wants what
why would you tell the president
everything you shouldn't
i wanted to be a guy you ever met these
guys that you talk to
and they don't say nothing but they
remember everything you say they'll sit
in the room and they'll just go boom
you'll never catch them doing something
like this
they never do this they're just they're
just focused and they're like they're
looking at everybody like this
they don't what is the matter with this
guy right but their computer right here
okay you said that no problem got it
what does this case sound good got it
still two hours later now one word has
come out they're the smartest person in
the room right that guy
those people weirded me out that's the
guy that needs to know everything
that's the guy that works for the cia
for 33 years that has
no aspirations of being a comey no
aspirations on being on tv no
aspirations of doing anything like that
that's the person what motivates that
type of person no it's a dna it's a
wiring it's not about motivation
it's just i it is who i am it's a wiring
there's not you like
no one can make you be like that i can't
make
herbie like that him be like that tommy
like that you're either like that or
you're not like that it's purely a dna
part so
all this stuff you read about well the
president the day you get you know
voted in they tell you everything no
they don't tell you okay i stand
corrected
this is not disney's book of secrets
yeah i don't know about them they go to
that little
leather book up so if you are the
president you're gonna say dude
just let me know right now there's
aliens and there's no aliens i gotta
know
you're gonna wanna you're gonna ask that
question sir we can't tell you i'm sorry
didn't obama say that
didn't he you got an obama no bush bush
got an interview with the jimmy kimmel
and jimmy kimmel asked this week obama
said something about it right didn't he
said something about what efos he said
something about trump this week in a
book i don't know if you saw that
he said uh yeah on mother sucker did you
actually do we have that as a story
boy he dropped down and uh kai do we
have that as a story or no can you put
that up
obama trump book uh uh you know but bush
was being interviewed by kimmel
and kimmel asked him a question says so
so let me ask you a question when you
become a president
do they take you into area 51 and tell
you all the dark secrets jfk all that
stuff what happened he says yes
are you willing to reveal any of it with
us no
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you